mean not good morning it's a third
targeting session but i hope you
at this point you're all energized so
it's a great pleasure to have non brown
from facebook ai who's going to talk
about
[Music]
deep reinforcement learning and other uh
applications of learning in games
complete information yeah
thank you
yeah so this is um on combining deep
reinforcement learning
uh and search for improved information
games um the motivation here is that we
want to create an algorithm kind of like
alpha zero or alpha you know alpha zero
but that can also play improved
information games like poker
so uh for some background
um i'm sure many of you know or pretty
much all of you know about alphago
alphago was this milestone achievement
in ai it was the first time that an ai
had beaten top humans in the game of go
um that said there were some things that
were not so satisfying about alphago one
it used human data and two it used
expert features um
so arguably the more impressive
achievement was followed up a year later
without the zero
so alpha zero is a single algorithm that
can play chess go and shogi and without
any human data and no expert features so
um
i think this is a very impressive
achievement that said it is limited to
perfect information games alpha zero is
not able to play an improved information
game like poker
um
and you know i'm sure that well the
question is well why uh and i'll cover
that in a little bit
and this is of course a problem because
perfect information games are a very
limited subset of the whole space of
games um
you know perfect information games
are games where all players know the
exact state of the world they both
observe the same thing but in a lot of
real world situations you have
situations where there's asymmetry in
what players observe
and so for example a lot of real world
situations like negotiations financial
markets
um international trade all of these can
be observed all these can be viewed or
modeled as imperfect information games
that involve hidden information
so be nice to have an algorithm that can
handle hidden information because
eventually we want to extend these
beyond just recreational board games
into the real world
now when it comes to improv information
games the standard benchmark um
and grand challenge for a long time was
poker
in 2017
uh my advisor and i made a bad day play
two-player texas holdem poker and was
able to beat top humans uh this was
fought up in 2019 with a six-player bot
that was able to beat top humans
um that said the techniques that were
used in these poker ais were very
different from the ones that were used
to play games like chess and go
and so we have this situation where
there's alpha zero which can play a lot
of perfect information games but can't
play poker and we have these ais that
can play poker but you know you could
run them in a game like go but it
wouldn't do very well
uh so can we have a single ai that can
play
both go and poker um and and a lot of
other games ideally all using the same
algorithm and at a strong or expert
human level and so that's the motivation
behind rebel
which we actually published in europe's
2020.
um
rebel stands for recursive belief-based
learning uh rebel provely converges to a
nash equilibrium in two player zeros in
games so it's a mini max the same thing
as a mini max equilibrium
um it is super human in two player no
limit texas holden poker and it uses far
less domain knowledge than any prior
poker bot
and in private information games rebel
reduces to an algorithm that's very
similar to alpha zero it's not quite
identical but
it's it's much closer than anything
that's come before
okay so i want to start with a
simplified overview of alpha zero and
then i'll talk about rebel
so to start with we have to define what
is a state in a game
so a state is a sufficient statistic it
contains all the information that's
needed in order to determine the optimal
next move uh in the game assuming that
both players are going to play optimally
now in a game like chess or go
a state is pretty much equivalent to a
picture of the board it's not exactly
the same so for example in go there's
this co rule where you can't repeat the
same board configuration
and so you can't just look at it you
can't just input the exist the the
current board into uh your your bot
because it won't know if that board
state has been repeated or not um and
this is also a thing in chess so in
chess i think if you um you can't repeat
the same board position three times or
there's a draw so you have to feed in a
few different snapshots of the previous
board states as well um that said
um in general when it comes to perfect
information games you can just feed in a
picture of the board and that you can
call that the state
um in the worst case a state in a
perfect information game could be the
entire sequence of actions that were
played
um
okay so that's a state
now in perp information games the value
of a state
is the unique value and this value is
unique of both players playing optimally
from that point forward
so for example if you were to look at
this chessboard and ask what is the
value for player white well the answer
is white assuming that it's white's turn
to act let's say so white can move their
their queen
to uh take the black bishop and that's
checkmate so the value for this state is
one for white because they're going to
win
and so a value network takes a state as
input and outputs an estimate of the
state value
now where does the value not come from
well there's a few different options so
one it could be a handcrafted heuristic
function this was used for example in
deep blue in their chest spot their
chestbot in 1997. uh it can be learned
by training on expert human games so you
you know train out a bunch of human data
um
feed in a board state see what the end
game outcome ended up being for these
human players that's how alphago is
trained or it can be learned through
self-play
so you have the bot play against itself
see who ends up winning and then you can
use that information to train the board
states that were encountered and so that
was used in alpha zero
okay
now
when it comes to a game like chess or go
in principle
you could just
solve the entire game uh in one go right
like in theory you could just do
backward induction
um and and figure out the optimal
strategy for the entire game the problem
is that games like chess or go are way
too large to be able to do that
and so what ends up happening instead is
search
so
the idea of search is you look some
number of moves ahead let's say five
moves ahead
you stop there and then you substitute a
value estimate of both players playing
perfectly from that point forward you
substitute the state value
and then you're only going to solve this
sub game
so for example you could do backward
induction alpha zero uses monte carlo
research the details of how this search
is performed is not too important but
all these search algorithms
have this high level framework
and if the value net is perfect
then
this will compute the optimal next move
for you to take and you can just keep
doing this recursively as you go down
the game tree and that's how you can can
play these games
um now in alpha zero the sub game grows
in size because they use multicultural
research
in principle rebel can do the same that
said for simplicity um we assume that
the subgame is fixed in size um and for
this talk i'll make the same assumption
it just everything still carries over it
just makes things a little bit more
complicated
so you can imagine a sub game is
containing every state that's reachable
in the next five moves
okay so the way alpha zero works is at
the start of the game it's going to
generate a sub game
and this is how it's both trained and
how it plays um it's going to generate a
sub game and then it's going to solve
this sub game assuming that the
leaf nodes the the nodes at the bottom
of this sub game have a value determined
by its value network
okay so it solves the sub game that
determines the next move um
and then it just repeats this process as
it goes down to game three um next move
generates the sub game solves that
that determines the next move keeps
going until you reach the end of the
game and then eventually you see
somebody wins let's say blue
and so now you're going to
use that final payoff
the fact that blue one as a training
example for all the states that you
encounter
and with some random exploration alpha
zero will eventually encounter every
single state and learn every state's
true value and so for this reason alpha
zero um
at least there is a form of it that
provably converges to the max
equilibrium in a perfect information
game
okay
so that's great but why doesn't this
work in improv information games
actually i should say before i go
forward is there any questions about how
alpha zero works
okay yeah question
i mean when the state space is too large
yeah this is where the theoretical
result that it's not actually going to
explore all of these states in the state
space but it's going to use a neural
network function approximation to be
able to generalize between similar
states
okay so why does this work in improved
information games
well the reason is that curve
information states spiritually defined
uh don't have unique values in
interpretation games
so let me give you an example
uh this is a toy game that i call rock
paper scissors plus so it is just like
rock paper scissors except if other
player throws scissors then the winner
receives two points and the loser loses
two points
and this is just to break the symmetry
of the game
and i'm showing here a sequential
version of the game where player 1 acts
and then player 2x without observing
what player 1 did so you see there's a
player one decision node where they
choose between rock paper and scissors
and then it goes to player two and then
player two acts and there's a dotted
line between the player two nodes which
signifies that player two doesn't know
which of those states those uh those
nodes they are in
okay now if you crunch the numbers the
nash equilibrium the minimax equilibrium
for this game is to choose rock and
paper with 40 probability and scissors
with 20 probability and if both players
do that then they both receive a payoff
an expectation of zero
now imagine we're going to imagine we
try to do search in this game we do a
deflated form of search
um
and
what does that look like well this is
what the sub game is going to look like
player one let's say we're just
searching one move ahead so player one
acts we look one move ahead we stop
there and we substitute a value estimate
of both players playing perfectly from
that point forward
so this is what the sub game would look
like it's player one they choose between
rock paper and scissors and then there's
a payoff of zero and the game ends
now the problem here is that there is
not enough information in this subgame
to determine player one's optimal
strategy
um player one might look at this and
conclude they could do one third one
third one third they could always throw
rock but there's not enough information
to arrive at the
mini max
policy of rock and paper with 40
probability scissors with 20 probability
so what's going wrong here
well um the problem is that we are
assuming that player two's policy is
going to be fixed regardless of what
player one does
and indeed if that were true if player
two were to always play the nash
equilibrium regardless of what player
one does
then player one could throw a rock with
100 probability and receive an expected
value of zero
but that's not what would actually
happen if player one were for example to
throw rock with 80 probability
then player two would shift their their
strategy they would start to always
throw paper
and the value of the rock action would
change it would become minus one
um now we're making an assumption here
which is that our
our algorithm is common knowledge so if
so we're assuming that um
the other player has access to our code
and they can see that our policy is to
throw rock with 80 probability
um and so therefore they're able to best
respond to it and that that is an
important assumption we're going to be
making um and it's actually a common
assumption that's made in game theory um
that said we are also going to assume
they don't have access to our random
seed so if we have a randomized
algorithm then they won't be able to
know which action we're actually
choosing
now i want to point out this is i think
the key difference between perfect
information games and imperfect
information games in
in an improved information game the
value of an action
changes
depending on the probabilities chosen
that's not true in a game like chess or
go in a game like chess if an action is
good it doesn't matter if you choose it
ten percent of the time or 100 of the
time it's gonna have the same expected
value that's not true in a game like
poker
and this also means that these these
nodes um
don't have unique values the value
depends
on the policy both before and after
okay
information sets
don't necessarily have unique values um
but there is an extension uh uh or a
more general form that does have so
that's that's what we're gonna end up
using
uh okay so how do we fix this well
yeah
so just to follow up on that question um
what we have to do is redefine a state
remember state has to be a sufficient
statistic it has to contain all the
information that's necessary to
determine the optimal next move
and
so
just asking what is the value of
throwing rock
that's not well defined there's not
enough information there to determine
the value of that state
so what's if you ask what's the value of
having thrown rock there's not enough
information there
but if you were to ask what is the value
of having thrown rock with 80
probability paper with 10 probability
scissors with 10 probability that value
is well defined and that value is in
this case negative 0.6
um
and so so this is how we're going to
overcome this problem we're going to
generate we're going to extend the uh
the definition of estates
to include the common knowledge
um belief probability distribution the
joint probability distribution over all
relevant nodes in the game tree now in
this simple example we only need to have
a probability distribution over one
player's nodes and the more complicated
case uh where the game is is longer
there's decisions that have to be made
by both players you actually need the
joint probability distribution uh over
over
notes so you need a proper distribution
for both players
okay so that's
the high level idea of rebel um this is
this is going to be like a key
ingredient to rebel and now i'll get
into the overview of rebel any questions
about this so far yep the joint
probability distribution over all
players is this always a product
distribution of my information
product with your information it's not
independent that's what you're asking um
it can be it can be dependent so for
example in poker if i have an ace if i
have a high probability of having an ace
then you're probably having aces lower
and so it's actually dependent
okay
there is a way to decompose it so that
uh well this is kind of a detail but
there is a way to to compress it
okay so now i'll get to rebel um so
before okay start off with we need to go
over regret minimization i'm going to
hope that a lot of you are familiar with
this because i'm going to go through it
quickly
um
the idea behind regret minimization is
that
on each iteration t
an adversary is going to pick
a hidden payoff for each uh for each
action in the game and then we're going
to pick a policy which is a probability
distribution over actions that we can
play
and after we do that we receive a payoff
um
which is the probability of each action
it's the way it times the uh you know
just the vector product of like the
probability distribution times the
utilities and our goal is we want to do
at least as well as about as well as the
single best action that we could have
taken in all the previous iterations
so we're going to define regret
as the utility of the regret of an
action as the utility of that action on
all the iterations
minus the utility that we've actually
received on all the iterations that have
been played
and if we're not talking about regret of
an action we're just talking about
regret in general we're going to say
it's the maximum regret over all the
actions
now a very useful property is that if
the average regret that is the sum of
the regrets divided by the number of
iterations is less than or equal to
epsilon for both players in a two-player
zero-sum game
then the average policies
of both players over all the iterations
the average over all the iterations
is a two epsilon minimax equilibrium
so this is how we converge to a max
equilibria we minimize regret for both
players over all these iterations
and one thing that is going to be really
important for later
it's the average policies that converge
not the final order but the average
um that said playing
playing an action from the average
policy is identical to just sampling a
random iteration and then sampling an
action from that iteration
so that that's actually gonna be pretty
important later
okay so what does this look like uh
concretely well let's take a look at
this rock paper scissors matrix game so
we have player one choosing a row
of rock paper scissors player two
choosing a column and i'm showing here
just the payouts for player one because
this is a two player zeros and game so
whatever player one receives player two
is going to receive the opposite
okay so in regret matching player one is
going to choose the probability
distribution of our actions let's say
one half rock 25 paper scissors
player two uh picks an action let's say
they choose scissors in this case
and their choice determines a payoff for
each of player one's actions
um so player one for rock gets a payoff
of one for paper gets a payoff of minus
one for scissors gets to pay for zero
and now we update the regrets for each
of those actions
so the regret for rock increases by the
value that they
could have received for choosing rock
with 100 probability
minus the
the minus the value they actually
received so 1 minus
0.25 the regret goes up by zero points
0.75 and you can update the regrets the
same way for paper and scissors
and now because the regret is higher um
you know you're kind of like have some
regret for having not played that in
previous iterations
now there's this algorithm called regret
matching
um and there's actually a lot of
algorithms that that can minimize regret
but uh the one that i'll talk about
right now is regret matching uh which
just says if you you should pick actions
proportional to the amount of positive
regret on those actions and there's a
theorem that says if you do this if you
pick
a probability distribution of our
actions in this way
then
your regret will be bounded
your average regret will be bounded by
roughly order one over screw t
so
if both players play regret matching
then their regrets are going to
average regrets are going to decrease
and eventually will converge to a mini
max equilibrium
okay
so that's a review of the regret
learning regret matching um what about
extensive form games sequential games
so counter factual regret minimization
is a generalization it's an extension of
regret minimization to uh sequential
games
now the idea here is that we have uh
what are called info set info states um
also known as info sets
and an info state is a player's decision
point of the game tree defined by their
obs their observed actions
and their uh and
uh just observations in general
so their actions and their and their
observations
so for example uh this node right here
at the start of the game is its own
decision point it's its own info state
these two nodes here
uh because there's a dotted line which
means that player two player one did not
observe which of these two actions
player two chose and so these two these
two nodes share an info state
um
so cfr is going to independently
minimize regret at each info state
what that means is for each of these
info states you're going to have a
regret value for each action left or
right here um because player one doesn't
know which of these two nodes they are
in
their
their strategy their policy has to
always be the same for both of those
nodes
and that means that the regrets for both
of those nodes are also also have to be
the same
so player one for this this for this
info state has two regret values one for
going left in both of these nodes and
one for going right in both of these
nodes
so every single info state in this game
is going to have its own uh regret
minimizer
its own uh regret value for each of its
actions
and they are independently going to run
something like regret matching
and counterfactual regret minimization
is a a way of modifying this so that the
regret for the entire game
is bounded by the sum
of the
regrets at each of the info states
sorry
what is i think the fact that
more than what you just said which
[Music]
because is a little bit more than that
it involves some like weighing of how
the regrets of how the rare values are
laid
um but besides that it's basically it's
basically that yes you just run
independent regrettablizers that i've
recently
okay
so this allows us to extend uh
recognization to sequential games
um now
there's this algorithm called cfrd that
was introduced
in uh in 2014
and this ends up being quite useful for
rebel um okay so the idea here is that
regret matching is one way to bound the
growth of regret but it's not the only
way um
the the important thing about counter
factual regret minimization is that it
says the regret for the entire game is
bounded by the sum of the regrets for
all the info states now it doesn't
matter how you keep the regrets for
those individual info states low as long
as they are kept low the sum of the the
regret for the entire game will also be
kept low
um
and so
there are a lot of ways that we could
keep the regrets low um what we do in
cfrd
uh i'm gonna try to
keep this intuitive which is we're going
to break up this game tree into two
levels
so we have uh we're just going to draw
this black line break it up into two
levels and
on
the top side of this line in all the
info states above this line we're going
to just run cfr as usual
and for the info states below this line
we are going to compute a policy that
has zero regret
for all the info states below that line
um
so info states
on the first level we choose cfr and
because we're running cfr independently
like see if like whenever you're running
regret a regret minimization algorithm
um it doesn't matter what you do in the
other info states if you run regret
matching in an info state that info
states regret is going to be bounded by
order one over square root t regardless
of what happens everywhere else in the
game tree
so all these info states above this line
are going to have regret that's bounded
by order one over square root t because
they are running cfr there
and the info states below this line
we are explicitly computing a policy
that has zero regret on every single
iteration
and so of course their regrets are also
bounded um now of course this seems kind
of silly because
you know the whole point of running an
algorithm like cfr is to try to compute
a policy that has your regret everywhere
and so now you're saying like well on
each cfr iteration we have to solve
a part of this game tree which seems
like a very expensive operation and yes
it is the original motivation for this
algorithm was to reduce the the memory
usage of the algorithm um at the cost of
increasing the computational complexity
by quite a bit um
but
where we're going to end up going with
this is that we can use function
approximation to eliminate this inner
loop of having to solve these these
nodes down here um and it ends up being
quite computationally efficient
zero instantaneous regret so you're
learning
um a pilot you're finding a policy that
has your regret conditional on the
policies that are played above that line
should i think of it as a
two level but like
like
like
the top part chooses
their
uh policies and because like i don't
know how you weigh the nodes in an
information set with what you just said
yeah can you explain a little bit yeah
i've actually gone through an example
okay so on each iteration uh for the
info states on the first level like
above this black line you're just gonna
set their policies
according to whatever cfr says to do so
let's say that something like this you
know 0.5 and then player 2 sets their
policies
the same way this is just done based on
the regrets of those notes
and then uh below that line
okay
so given these policies for these
players you have some probability
distribution over each of these nodes
right you can work out the math and it
says there's a 12.5 chance that you're
in this node 37.5 chance that you're in
this node and so on
and so now we're going to compute a
policy that's optimal
given that information so in that case
um that's going to be in these in this
info state well you're usually in this
right node and so you go you should go
left
with 100 probability
and this info state you're usually in
this left node and so you should go
right i should go right with 100
probability
now this
policy
um
is going to ensure that your regret
is always non-positive
right because
if you
then update your regrets for each of
these info states like the regret here
is is
your regret update is going to be zero
you know you're you're choosing the best
action you could have received for that
iteration
so does that answer your question no
okay
um
okay
so
this is still going to convert to a
minimax equilibrium because the regrets
on the first level are bounded as usual
by cfr and the regrets on the second
level are always non-positive
now there's there is um one thing i
should point out here i'm keeping this
kind of simple in that all these nodes
down here belong to player one so it's
really easy to compute what the optimal
policy is now if you have
more like both player one and player two
nodes essentially you have to
solve
a a subgame
um and how do you do that well you do
that by just running cfr you know you
could recursively run the same algorithm
for all uh for the for the uh for the
bottom level
and yeah like i said it's very expensive
but just bear with me it'll make more
sense as as we get a little farther
okay
so now
i want to talk about decomposition um
given the policies on the first level
the second level can be decomposed into
subgames that can be solved separately
so given these policies on the top line
down here this is a sub game the the
optimal policy in this in this info
state has nothing to do with the author
policy in this info state they can be
solved completely independently
um and so this is what we call a sub
game it's it's a piece of the game that
is uh can be you can compute the optimal
policy independent from another part of
the game tree
now um
in particular i'm going to define a
public belief state as a joint
probability distribution over nodes at
the root of a sub game
so here the public belief state is you
know 12.5 percent on this node 37 37.5
percent on this node and then you
normalize that it all sums to one and
again in a more complicated setting
you'd have to have the joint problem
distribution for um
uh for all the nodes and it could they
could belong to like multiple players
for example
so uh
how do you define some games in the
sense uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dotted lines and verify connective
components
and these are voice objects that's right
yes the subjects have to be uh something
has to be its own uh completely separate
from from the other parts of the game
tree uh and so
this happens a lot actually so in a game
like you know in a lot of recreational
games there's public actions and so
you know if somebody
publicly takes one action then
everything that happens after that point
you can solve completely separately from
something that happened after a
different public action um conditional
on knowing the probability that that
public action was taken
um and so that's what we're doing here
we're saying like conditional on knowing
these probabilities we can solve this
part of the game tree completely
separately from this part of the game
tree
now there are some games where you don't
have um this this these public actions
and you can't decompose the game tree
and uh there it's still an open question
about what you do to uh to be able to
solve pieces of the game um but but this
ends up being quite useful for a lot of
a lot of situations
or like there's an imperfect recall
recall is also a bit you have to
probably
um
okay so public belief state is a joint
probability distribution over nodes at
the root of the subgame
and uh the nice thing about public
belief states
is that they end up being equivalents
they share a lot of properties
with perfect information states as we
previously defined them so a perfect
information game state you remember like
think about a chess board
um has a unique value if both players
play optimally from that point forward
well same thing with public belief
states
a public belief state has a unique value
for uh for that subject like each
subgame has a unique value
um
and
that ends up yeah so that's how we train
our value network um here like the whole
challenge here was that we didn't have
unique values before but now we do
so
what we can do is train a value network
to predict the value of sub games rooted
at a public belief state so the input to
this value network is a public belief
state that is a joint probability
distribution over nodes
and the output is the value of the
public belief state
now there's a subtlety here which is
that even though the value of the public
belief state is unique
the value of the nodes or the info
states at the root of that public belief
state of that cell game are not
necessarily unique
um we addressed this in the paper but
it's kind of complicated so i will just
gloss over this for now
um
okay
so that's how we get our value net
and how do we train the value now well
we do it the same way as alpha zero we
do it through self-play
so this is what the algorithm ends up
looking like
um
we start at the beginning of the game
with an initial public release date
which is just you know determined by the
initial rules of the game
uh we generate a sub game
and then we solve it using cfr
and then at the bottom of this game tree
at the bottom of this sub game there's
going to be a leaf public belief states
we will get the values of that instead
think of again like cfrd normally we
would do this recursive cfr call where
we solve the sub game on each iteration
of cfr instead we're going to query our
value network and ask it what is the
value of the subnet and it's going to
output a value
and that's how we're going to to solve
this again
and again i meant
going back earlier i said the average
strategy of cfr converges to an
equilibrium but you can equivalently
just choose a random iteration and and
sample from that random iteration so
that's what we end up doing we're going
to stop this operation on a random
iteration
um play the subgame policy on that
random iteration and that leads us to a
leaf public belief state
now we repeat this process we generate a
new subgame
solve it
um using cfr
play that policy on a random iteration
and keep going all the way down the game
tree until we reach the end of the game
and then eventually we get an outcome
something like blue wins
and so then we use that value
as a training example for all the public
belief states that we encountered
all the way down the game tree
and this looks very similar to how alpha
zero looks and in fact if you run this
on a perfect information game
it's it's very similar to alpha zero
you know states end up public belief
states end up collapsing to the
traditional definition of state um as
defined in perfect information games
the training is very similar and we have
a theorem that says
with
tabular tracking of public belief state
values rebel will converge to a nash
equilibrium at mini max equilibrium and
two player zeros in games and finite
time
um
and yeah so it'll converge to one over t
whatever square root t mini max
equilibrium where t is the number of cfr
iterations that you run in each subgame
okay questions about that
yeah what about the constant in this
convergence rate
it's range no sorry the constant in the
convergence rate is there the number of
states or something like this oh yes
there's uh there's a pretty big concept
that's attached so i could say like
order one is for routine um
and
yes in practice of course you don't
actually want to typically track the
release state values um you want to use
neural network production approximation
and your value function and also ideally
a policy network to be able to
generalize between similar similar
states
so when you generate the game all the
leaves of that tree must be pbs's like
because
so all these graphs
so you hope that
whatever you play has
is likely to lead you to at least
small-sized things
that have gps yeah i mean
like every game has a public belief
stage it's a question of how big it is
um
so i mean like the whole game is itself
a uh sorry
every game has a sub game it's
especially how big that game is and how
big the root of that game is so like you
know the whole game for example
is is a sub game and um you know it
might be there's only like five sub
games in this whole game
in which case this is yeah gonna be a
problem to run uh but that's that's you
know one of the interesting directions
for future work like what do you do
when these belief states are massive and
um
you can't plug them into a value network
so the network would have to generalize
or close to the sizes of pbs i mean like
uh yeah if uh
does that make sense like uh
conveniently in poker which is the game
that we ran this on uh all the public
belief states have a roughly the same
size so the political league state of
poker would be
a probability distribution over the
hands that you can have and the probably
distribution of our hands that i can
have and also like the public publicly
observed sequence of actions
and so
the number of possible hands that i can
have or that you can have stays fixed
pretty much throughout the entire game
um there's always going to be roughly 1
326 possible hands so
yeah you don't really have to generalize
over different sizes
in poker now that said again yeah
there's still interesting questions
about how to generalize this to even
more complicated settings where like the
size of the pbs can change throughout
the game
or in different parts of the game
okay
yeah
um could you do something similar for
games that have cooperated
yeah so we actually did do something
like this uh for hanabi um which i'll
talk a little bit about later
okay so uh what do the empirical results
look like so we actually played this
against both prior pokerbots and we
played against a top human professional
um
so
in terms of uh comparison of firebots
it's very close to state-of-the-art it
doesn't quite beat libratus which is the
bot that beats top humans in a
two-player and a little bit poker in
2017. by the way this is all for for
two-player nolan texas holding poker
um you can see rebel
the main benchmark here is baby
tartanian eight this was the champion of
the 2016 annual computer poker
competition which is our bot actually so
libratus beats it by 63 plus or minus 14
uh chips per hand
rebel beats it by nine that said when
you compare to top humans
lebronus beat the top humans by 147 plus
or minus 39 ships per hand
rebel beats them beats one of them the
best performing one by 165 plus or minus
69. now i'm uh hesitant to claim
that rebel is actually better than the
broadest in fact i don't think that's
the case i think this is just an example
of variance um playing a part
um but i think there is it's quite clear
that at the very least rebel is uh
beating uh this top human professional
and by a pretty substantial margin why
didn't you play rebel brothers
uh i couldn't have access to the source
code
well i don't own it though
it's uh it's at cmu this was done at
facebook rebel was done on facebook and
then also libraries is very expensive to
operate so rebel runs on
you actually don't even need a gpu you
can run it on like you know a c on a few
cpus uh cpu cores the broadest takes
about 2000 cpu cores to run
so it's it's pretty difficult to get
enough hands in to to measure that
um okay we also i mean again the nice
thing about rebel and the whole point of
rebel is that it's general it's
generalizable it it's a general it can
be applied to other games as well and so
we actually ran this also in liar's dice
um
and again there there's not really
benchmark bots that we can play against
but we do show empirically that it
converges um to a to an equilibrium in
this game
and in fact we open source the bot and
you can download it and play around with
it at this url
okay so one thing i should point out
also regarding the poker results um even
though rebel i would say is not as
strong as lebronus um lebron has used a
lot of domain knowledge to to achieve
its level of performance um it used
information about
you know
what hands are similar um a lot of
future engineering um
rebel basically does none of that and it
takes out a lot of that stuff
it's still still discretizes the action
space that's the one thing i would say
like the biggest use of domain knowledge
but besides that it's actually quite
minimal
and so that's really what we're aiming
for with this with this
in rebel paper in
like you know in alphago
visual
aspects of the board are for the first
like there are
the prefix
of
[Music]
that's a good question so um i'm a
little rushed on the details of that my
collaborator was the one that was mostly
responsible for the
network architecture um
i
feel like even if i give an answer the
answer would probably be different today
like the awful choice would be different
today than it was two years ago
um so i don't yeah i can't really
comment on that right now
okay so key takeaways uh rebel perfectly
converges to a national equilibrium in
two players there are some games that is
a mini max equilibrium
and this is true for both perfect
information and interpreter permission
games uh rebel achieves superhuman
performance in poker while using far
less domain knowledge than any prior
pokerbot
and rebel reduces to an algorithm
similar to alpha zero in perfect
information games
now that said there are some major
challenges that remain uh so one is
how to deal with more information so the
input to rebels state value function
is
a probability a joint probability
distribution over all info states
that are that are feasible that are
consistent with um the
the sequence of actions that have
occurred in the game so far the public
the public information
now in texas hold on poker there's 1 326
possible hands and so the input to your
value network is at most 2652
for heads up poker
but what do we do if there's far more
hidden information you know what if you
have five card poker five card draw
poker or what if you have a game like
stratego where you have you know these
40 different units that could be
arranged in any possible configuration
um
you can't just plug in a 40 factorial
distribution into a into a to a neural
network
um
so that's one challenge we've actually
had two paper recent papers that address
this problem
one was published at nurbs in 2021
and so this is on scalable online
planning via reinforcement learning fine
tuning the idea here is that we replace
tabular search techniques with a neural
network
kind of like reinforcement learning
operation a fine tuning operation that
happens at test time
and we also have a paper that's going to
be presented at iclear in a couple
months on a fine-tuning approach to
believe state modeling so this addresses
the question of like what do you do
if the number of possible
in uh
you know info states or nodes is too
large to feed into a into a value
network
we show that you can actually have a
generative belief model that will be
able to sample from that distribution
and we can fine-tune that model um while
doing search
and this actually we do experiments on
hanabi and we show that um that this
actually achieves state vr performance
in hanavi and can be extended to
versions of hanabi that have far more uh
like seven cards instead of five because
it can handle the increase in
information
uh finally i think another interesting
challenge is um learning the dynamics
model so there was a recent paper that
came out um called mu0
where it's an extension of alpha zero
that learns to play games like chess and
go without even knowing the rules of the
game
i thought this was a really impressive
achievement especially because it makes
it much more useful for the real world
where sometimes the rules are not so
well defined as they are in chess and go
um it's still an open question of can we
extend rebel to do something similar
and finally um going beyond two player
zero some games remains a very
interesting challenge and this is
something that i personally have been
working on and i'm very excited about as
well
okay so i will stop there and um take
questions with the little time i have
left thank you
thank you very much for the very
interesting talk any questions
[Music]
a little more about the last point you
made about multiplayer games like what
is the state of the art there
in terms of i don't know poker or other
games
so uh poker
poker has a unique structure so we were
able to make a superhuman bot for six
player poker
but that's because poker has
a very adversarial structure to it that
makes it very difficult for players to
cooperate and i don't think that the
techniques would
extend to all they certainly don't
extend to all multiplayer games out of
the box they extend to some but
certainly not all
and so i've been work looking at this
game diplomacy um which involves a lot
of collaboration in addition to
competition um there
the state of the art is um
you know there's still a lot of open
questions um it's not even clear what
solution concept we're really looking
for in two players there are some games
there's the mini max equilibrium which
has this nice property that says you're
going to beat
any any other player guaranteed in the
long run if you're or at least you're
not going to lose to them if you play
the mini max equilibrium
um once you go beyond two players here
some games you don't have that
theoretical guarantee anymore for any of
the equilibrium concepts and so i would
argue that um what you need to do is
look at
data on the population of players that
you might be up against so collecting
human data and being able to leverage
that human data and incorporating that
into these kinds of algorithms is quite
a difficult challenge
so for multiplayer poker it does it does
not end up being kind of like the
running uh counterfactual regret or it
is a multiplayer poker we do actually
just run cfr so we take techniques that
are pretty similar to the two-player
zero-sum techniques
um
skeleton will make them more efficient
at some uh new techniques and we show
that that works in six player poker um
so they're the solution because it's
some kind of correlated equilibrium
ultimately
i think in practice it ends up
converging pretty close to a nash
equilibrium
technically it is of course correlated
equilibrium though yeah
um and i think that the fact that that
works is i think
arguably a quirk of poker
any further questions
right
thank you very much thanks
you